The Authority was one of the coolest
groups ever in DC Comics check this out
so Apollo is basically a former U.S
soldier that has all the powers of
Superman Ginny spark was born at the
stroke of midnight on New Year's Eve in
1900 so she basically has immortality
and she can control electricity the
engineer is a chick named Angela spica
who basically has a liquid body with
nanites in her bloodstream so she can
create solid objects but she also has
shape-shifting and flight abilities the
Swift is a chick whose Powers were
activated when a comet flew by Earth so
she basically has flight enhanced
strength and super speed the doctor is a
guy whose Powers become stronger every
time he dies and comes back to life the
midnighters basically The Punisher and
Jack Cooper gains his powers from a
symbiotic link with the city that he's
in meaning he can control entire cities
they're a really cool team make sure you
guys follow for more